je vous propose à présent une balade
architecturale sur la côte basque dans
cette station balnéaire lancée par
napoléon iii
biarritz est un véritable musée à ciel
ouvert jean jacques duffau jean moulin
biarritz recèle des trésors des trésors
plus ou moins cachés des trésors
d'architecturé délirante pas ce qui va
en vie commençons donc la balade par
l'une des maisons les plus symboliques
de la ville
la ville avait déjà fait rêver tous les
biarrots parce qu'elle est resté
abandonné pour des problèmes de
succession pendant longtemps maintenant
est divisée en appartements
celle ci est encore presque abandonné et
mails va faire l'objet je pense
une réhabilitation une transformation
bientôt autrefois le château d'ilbarritz
était la propriété d'un excentrique
passionnés de musique le baron de l'épée
cette maison a été construite
principalement pour mettre un homme qui
après lors des différentes ventes a été
déplacée démonter et qui se trouve au
sacré coeur à paris récemment transformé
en chambres d'hôtes la ville là le
goéland offre trois chambres avec vues
ces petites merveilles qui ont failli
disparaître à cause de la spéculation
immobilière sont désormais classés une
procédure qui concerne plus de 800 villa
et bâtiments on pouvait craindre une
réaction difficile de la part des
propriétaires parce que ça veut dire que
on peut pas remplacer une villa ou un
immeuble de deux étages par un immeuble
de quatre étages ou de six étages la
réaction a été dans l'ensemble
extrêmement positive parce que je crois
qu'il ya une très grande fierté de la
ville par rapport à son patrimoine
le patrimoine d'un ancien village de
pêcheurs transformé par l'impératrice
eugénie en ville princière
princière c'est ce que l'on pourrait
dire de la maison d'edmond rostand elle
n'est pas à biarritz mais à
cambo-les-bains à l'intérieur du pays
basque l'extérieur est très intégrée
dans la nature néo basque et l'intérieur
vous allez le découvrir et totalement
éclectique déborde de de décors de
toutes sortes on a du baroque au nahd
l'anglais on a dû chinois
c'est extraordinaire c'est un véritable
décor théâtral ce décor charmant et de
bourse les pays avec l'argent que lui a
rapporté cyrano de bergerac une pièce à
succès
la preuve le succès l'argent ça ne fait
pas le bonheur mais cela permet quand
même de réaliser quelques fantasmes
située à hendaye le château d'abbadie en
est l'illustration parfaite
il avait une fortune colossale qu'il
avait héritée de ses parents
donc besoin de travailler construit
entre 1860 et 1870 par viollet le duc le
château d'abbadie mérite lui aussi une
petite visite
une visite qui vous permettra de devenir
copropriétaires puisque si j'en crois
victor hugo la façade d'une maison
appartient aussi à celui qui la regarde